[music]
Jonathan:
The Halftime Retreat is an opportunity to step back
in your Princeton experience, look at it, evaluate it,
Jonathan:
appreciate it, most importantly, and then to go
back into it as kind of a changed person and more
Jonathan:
confident in what you want to do with the rest
of your time there.
[music]
Gracie:
Sophomore year just kind of jumps on you.
You don't really expect all these decisions to bombard you
Gracie:
all at the same time, but they really do all bombard you
within a few weeks from each other.
Gracie:
And after Halftime, I definitely realized that there
were certain things that I wanted to do
Gracie:
while here at Princeton.
And Halftime helps clarify that.
[music]
Jilly:
So, at Halftime, I made a ton of new friends.
I must have made at least 30 new friends.
Jilly:
And we still keep in touch by having lunch.
Student:
The best part was the sledding.
There was so much snow.
[music]
Russell:
There was an exercise that we did, and we had to
rate our satisfaction in certain portions of our lives.
Russell:
Having that moment to really think about what I wanted to
do, and what made me personally satisfied --
Russell:
in the end, it was a rewarding exercise.
Leana:
The exercises were really wonderful in terms of
going over what we wanted to do in our future.
Leana:
But the real fun happened after hours, I'm not going to
lie, when all the board games that were stacked in the
Leana:
corner were ravaged, and taken across the floor.
There were games of--
Leana:
I'm trying to remember what there was--
there was Scattergories, there was Taboo, there were
Leana:
different games of cards going on.
But the most intense of them all was definitely Mafia.
[crowd laughing, cheering]
Jessica:
It's just an incredible thing to do.
It's so much fun.
Jessica:
You meet so many people.
And it's very relaxed.
[music]
Jilly:
If you're thinking about going on Halftime,
definitely do it.
Jilly:
Because you'll learn more about who you are and how
other people are making some of the same
Jilly:
decisions that you are.
Russell:
It was like a summer camp in the middle of the
winter with college kids.
Russell:
And it was a great experience.
Gracie:
Halftime was a lot of fun.
[laughter]
Leana:
Halftime is a totally wonderful experience.
There are no downsides.
Leana:
I can't really think of a single reason
you shouldn't go.
Leana:
It was the time of my life.
[music]